no guys it's been a while since I've
made a video in this one I'm just gonna
give you a few updates on what's to come
in 2018 also make sure you stick around
to the end as I'll be giving some
previews on future videos some of you
will already be aware that I also do
flow arts as well as Aikido I think this
helps with coordination body movement
and general flow with that in mind I
thought well stew I benefit from such as
traveling and spending time outdoors
recently I read a quote in all sensei's
book the outer peace
it says study how water flows in the
Valley Stream smoothly and freely
between the rocks everything mountains
rivers plants and trees should be your
teacher but made me think I might expand
on the type of videos that I'm doing I'd
like to shoot more outdoors traveling
and generally anything that I think that
might be inspirational
remember Aikido is more than just
training on the map in my opinion it's
into everything we do I'll be interested
to know what people think about the
direction I'm going so feel free to
leave comments below also as you may
realize I've been traveling in Thailand
and Laos
I felt quite a lot of footage there
including two martial arts clubs live
visit and we're putting together videos
for them soon so keep your eye out what
stars out there are purchasing more
camera equipment including a drone which
I've yet to film or hopefully they
should help us improve the quality of
all videos so anyway without further ado
let's see what we've got planned for
[Music]